hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter one of
language truth and logic a jair after
setting out the criterion of
verifiability which is really one of the
central concepts and fulcrums of this
entire work will provide us with some
useful examples so we can see how this
criterion is actually applied and he'll
give you many many more throughout the
rest of the work but these are the three
sets of examples that follow immediately
on setting out the the criterion of
verifiability
and the criterion let's remind ourselves
basically says that in order for a
statement to be meaningful unless it's a
tautology in which case it's always true
it has to have some literal significance
and that literal significance consists
in being able to say what sort of
experiential or sometimes he says
empirical propositions or claims would
follow from that so what what is it that
you could in fact verify by observation
at least in principle and at least as
being probable there are you know
different versions of verification AER
says
that in principle is enough so we can
ask ourselves for any given set of
claims or assertions what would have to
be the case in order for us to actually
say that this is true what would make us
agree to this so he uses as a prime
example to begin with this notion that
the world of Sense experience is
altogether unreal and some people do say
things like that so saying that that our
Sense experience is a deception or
planted in our minds by an evil genius a
la Descartes or that perhaps we're in
the matrix or anything along those lines
we want to say that the world of Sense
experience is altogether false we're
unable to verify that why he says that
well we have to admit our senses do in
fact deceive us you know we could look
at the examples that Descartes uses in
the meditations and discourses like the
round tout the square tower that at a
distance appears round or the stick
that's put into the water appears bent
but it's not really bent the Sun looks
like it's a little small ball but we
know it's actually much much larger we
go on and on and on with these but air
says well how do we know that our senses
are deceiving us well we rely on other
observations coming from our senses he
says that we may as a the result of
having certain sensations expect other
sensations to be obtainable which are in
fact not obtainable you know for for
example we drink a drink and we think
that it's going to add a certain taste
because of the way it looks and it
tastes very different or though what's
going on there but we are sensing right
we're using Sense experience to do that
so he says we say that the senses
deceive us because the expectations to
which our sense experiences give rise do
not always accord with what we
subsequently experience so we're relying
on our senses to substantiate
whether or not the judgments that we
have that are based on our sensations
are correct or not
so we're verifying those but can we
globalize it could we say well all of my
sense experiences are actually deceptive
what experience would lead you to
conclude that how would you in fact make
that claim and verify it Eyre says that
there there simply is no way you cannot
do that there's as he says no
conceivable observation or set of
observations which would show us that
all of our sense experiences or the
world of sense experience is unreal he
says that that there's there's no
possibility of it so anyone he says who
condemns the sensible world is a world
of mere appearance as opposed to reality
is saying something which according to
our criterion of significance is
literally nonsensical now they might be
saying something that has a metaphorical
meaning or an emotive meaning they may
might be saying oh the world is
valueless it sucks you know it's no good
but that would be an emotive meaning
right there'd be a value judgment being
made there if they're literally saying
that the world of appearance does not
give us any reality that there's
something lying behind it or perhaps
everything is empty air would say well
there's no way to verify that the next
thing that he talks about is the
argument or let's say rather being more
technical controversy between monists
and what he's calling pluralists which
pretty much everybody was not a monist
right but we could expand this we could
talk about do lists we could talk about
those who believe that there's this
determinant number of entities or
anything like that so the monist what
makes them aloneness is the assertion
that metaphysically everything is one
Parmenides is is a prime example Spinoza
another prime example Hegel is sometimes
been interpreted as a monas because of
his
discussion of spirit or Geist or mine
right
and so the monist is asserting that
reality is one substance the pluralist
is saying no there's more than one thing
it could be a million things could be
you know three things could be whatever
you want they're just saying reality is
multiple substances now that sounds like
it makes sense right
isn't there a possible controversy there
ear says well how would you verify that
he goes on and he says that it's
admitted both by monists and pluralists
that it's impossible to imagine any
empirical situation which would be
relevant to the solution of their
dispute you can provide all sorts of
intellectual reasonings for it but
there's no there's no observations that
you could make that would lead you to
say that there are indeed multiple
substances why not because well you
might say well the pluralist is actually
at an advantage here they can like say
well look here's if we're gonna pretend
to be G more here's one hand here is
another yeah but the hands might be said
to be part of this one substance that's
me okay so far so good
you got me and then you got the track
board I'm clearly not the same thing as
the chalk board or me and you
well monist can say i understand that
you see things that way but it is in
fact these are just modes of one primal
substance you think that they're
actually different from each other but
they're not actually different from each
other and at that point you have to say
what how how can you actually prove this
the Monas will say well I can't prove it
by empirical observation as a matter of
fact empirical observation would leave
you to think that there's multiple
things but that's where empirical
observation has gone wrong there's no
way to verify or for that matter falsify
the assertion of the monist which means
that the monist is literally saying
according to err nonsense
says that we're told there's no possible
observation that could give any
probability either to the assertion that
reality
one substance or to the assertion that
it was many we must conclude that the
neither assertion is significant again
and again significant he means in a
literal sense where we're talking about
you know matters of fact if we're
talking about our emotions or we're
being metaphorical or poetic well we can
say all this stuff that we want but
that's a different use of language the
third one that he talks about is the
realists and the idealists and here he
brings in a little bit of a discursive
sin2 talking about art and how we
determine whether it's genuine art or
not he says a simple illustration will
help to demonstrate this let us suppose
a picture is discovered and the
suggestion made that it was painted by
Goya there is a definite procedure for
dealing with such a question what is the
definite procedure the experts the art
historians the people who engage in you
know restoration whoever that is right
they examine the picture to see in what
ways it resembles the accredited works
of Goya and to see if it bears any marks
which are characteristic of a forgery
they look up contemporary records for
evidence of the existence of a picture
and so on and so you know what what is
going on here they're carrying out a
process of inquiry and research and much
of this is an appeal to empirical
propositions is there a name for this
painting that corresponds to the little
you don't think I'm a the frame here
that's in this book over here that's
that's an empirical fact that you could
either say yes it is or no it isn't or
perhaps we need more research you can
look for marks of forgery that's going
to be a matter of probabilities of
course it doesn't have to be absolutely
certain about it and as he points out it
could be that these experts will
actually disagree but here's the key
thing each one knows what empirical
evidence would go to confirm or
discredit his opinion each of them could
say listen I think it's a forgery
because I see these signs here but I
would be willing to have my mind changed
if there was some way of accounting for
how these came to be
or if I found out that these aren't
really marks of a forgery and the other
could say I I think it's genuine because
it really does resemble Goya's stuff and
that but I could be convinced otherwise
if I found out that you know looking
through a book he had an understudy who
did similar paintings and described this
painting so they're talking about
empirical propositions that could verify
or disconfirm the hypothesis or judgment
that they are making what about if we
talk about this painting in light of the
realists versus idealist now what are
what are realists in this sense this is
a metaphysical doctrine that says that
you know physical objects things that we
think are real perhaps other things as
well but let's just stick with physical
objects they are objectively real
they're outside of us they are not just
object or ideas in our minds or in the
divine mind they really exist when I
turn my back it's still there
looking at it right now now you see it's
there of course but the realist says
that the painting whoever it's by
whether it's by Goya or not is
objectively real and they don't mean
objectively real in the sense that Gore
really painted it but somebody really
painted it and it exists independently
of any observer the idealist asserts
instead that the painting is a set of
ideas in our minds or in the mind of God
or you know perhaps in some other mind
right and and those who think that we're
actually living within a
computer-generated matrix would be in a
certain sense idealists in this sense
wouldn't they so he goes on and he says
in the ordinary sense of real in which
it is opposed to a losery the reality of
the picture is not in doubt they've
satisfied themselves that it is real by
having a correlated series of sensations
of sight and sensations of touch but
could they discover whether the picture
was real in the sense in which real as
opposed to ideal says clearly there's no
decision procedure for this there's no
way to do that and then he concludes in
this is so the problem is fictitious
according to our criteria so each of
these provides us with an example of how
this criterion of verifiability would be
applied to the typical metaphysical
disputes that were coming up around the
time of a Jair and which do arise in our
own time and we'll probably be around
for centuries yet to come
or they go far back into the history of
philosophy as well
according to err none of these actually
are verifiable and so the metaphysics
that they claim to express is merely
nonsense in a literal sense
you